there are a bunch of publicly available
university courses on the internet that
you can take for free in this video seth
golden and sam crombee will teach you
how to find the best course for you and
how to get the most out of the courses
you take welcome to our video course on
learning from free public college
computer science courses on the web
this video is a collaboration between
college compendium and the amazing free
code camp
i'm seth golden and together with samuel
crombie we've put together this course
helping you to be successful within
self-guided education
we're going to dive deep into the
auto-didactic nature of learning on the
internet learning from public courses
and why you should consider trying it
we'll discuss choosing a topic and a
course to learn about that topic and
then making the most of your experience
and then at the end we have a couple
vlogs where we review real courses and
discuss our thoughts
this video is broken into chapters you
can skip to if you're interested in a
specific section if you prefer to read
we will have a brief written
accompanying article available on free
code cam
before i end this introduction i
encourage you to check out college
compendium sometime during or after
finishing this video college compendium
is a free non-profit open source
compilation of over a thousand public
university computer science courses from
awesome colleges across north america
you can also access public textbooks as
complementary material on the site
collegecompendium.org
we hope that the resources available
there and this video are helpful to you
are you excited to begin by the end of
this video you'll be prepared to audit
courses on the web and succeed in them
hi everyone my name is sam and alongside
seth in this
series of videos i'm going to be talking
about how to audit college courses
now in this section before we even dive
into what that actually means i want to
take a step back and talk about learning
on the internet
and taking even another step back
talking about learning what is learning
well merriam-webster defines learning as
the activity or process of gaining new
knowledge or skill by studying
practicing being taught or experiencing
something
so you wake up and stub your toe getting
out of bed you've learned something new
you go forage for berries or i don't
know eat raw meat and then you get sick
boom you've learned
and so like as humans learning is
us being awake and conscious and as we
experience new things we store that
information and reference it later so
that we can get smarter
and over time as societies kind of
developed
institutions popped up to formalize this
learning in a setting that was helpful
to that society and so when we think
about today what it means to learn
through an institution
over 99 of people born in 2022 are going
to be learning up until at least primary
school in some sort of formal
government-mandated environment which
means that if you're watching this video
you've most likely experienced this in
one form or another
and so you'll be familiar with some of
the characteristics of what it means to
learn through an institution
first structure you go to the same place
every day you interact with the same
people the same teachers and barring
differences in semesters or years it's
really something that has been well
thought out and is very consistent in
terms of
what you're learning how you're learning
it where you're learning it stays the
same
two there's a lot of sequence in how you
learn in that
what you've previously learned what
you're currently learning and what you
are going to learn has again been really
well thought out and there's an order
that makes sense so that your knowledge
compounds on top of itself over time
three this institutional learning is
compulsory and that you don't really
have to ask yourself why am i learning
you know really the answer is because
you have to
there's nothing very philosophical about
it otherwise you're breaking the law or
your guardians are breaking the law
so the incentives are you have to do it
and fourth because you are in person or
interacting with peers
and professors and buildings and
different things
especially in
topic areas like hard sciences we have
to interact with something it's very
experiential
and so learning through institutions is
one type of learning and a distinct form
of learning that isn't mutually
exclusive but it's different is
autodidactic learning where a lot of
these questions that are answered for
you when learning through an institution
are solved in that determining the topic
you study
where you're studying it when you study
it and how you study it those are all
questions that you actually have to
answer for yourself
and whether you know it or not you've
probably engaged in kind of self-guided
learning at some point in your life and
it's not a new concept it's something
that people have done for quite a long
time and in fact some of our greatest
minds have been autodidactic learners
learning outside of a formal institution
so it's distinct from learning in a
school because there's a lot more
flexibility in terms of spatially not
having to be in a location in terms of
the content you learn
the form of content the type of content
you learn there's a lot more flexibility
in general
two the learning is
most often non-sequential and that you
don't have someone telling you you need
to learn this in abc order it's really
up to you and that can be very difficult
three there are other incentives
for self-guided auto didactic learning
because there isn't someone telling you
you have to go to school you have to
really think about why am i wanting to
learn this it's a different incentive
model and ultimately you may be engaging
with friends who are also learning
alongside you and you may be engaging
with you know an expert or an instructor
but ultimately it's an independent
activity as compared to learning in a
formal institution
and when you think about the barriers to
entry when it comes to time and cost of
auto didactic learning on the internet
it can be really steep because again
in a learning environment where in an
institution
those questions are being answered for
you for the most part so when you're
learning in an auto didactic manner
you're answering the questions of what
do i want to learn why do i want to
learn it when and how do i learn it are
there prerequisites for what i'm
learning are the resources that i'm
using trustworthy accurate how am i
going to stay on schedule how am i going
to stay motivated how am i going to stay
engaged
and again
autodidactic learning and learning
through institutions there's a lot of
overlap and there's a lot of
similarities but a lot of the questions
that are answered in a formal
environment aren't answered for you when
you're learning on your own
and it's a shame that this is so
difficult and that so few people are
able to really kind of figure it out
because there are so many great
resources on the internet that really
any topic at any skill level has quite a
bit of supporting material
and so
you have auto didactic learning you have
learning through institutions
these are two distinct things but
they're also two very similar things and
so it's not a matter of going to school
or dropping out in fact it's a matter of
how do we take
what learning through an institution can
provide us in terms of what it's figured
out for how to most effectively learn
and apply that to auto-didactic learning
and self-guided study
and we'll talk about later why we've
chosen auditing college courses as a way
of thinking about learning on the
internet but as a little precursor the
answer is because when you are learning
through one of these courses that's
available um particularly when it comes
to computer science courses
it has a lot of structure and similarity
to what you would learn in a school and
so it's a great entry point into
learning on the web this huge umbrella
of how do i learn on the internet and we
believe that if you learn how to learn
on the internet you can really reach any
goal
on any topic at any place and so that's
what we're going to be establishing in
this course and talking about going
forward
learning
learning on the internet and now this
process of auto didactic learning how do
you
formalize that and how do you get better
at it and how do you apply it to
something like auditing so in the next
section seth is going to talk about what
it means to audit a course
now that we've talked about auto
didacticism and discussed a broad
overview of learning on the web what
does it mean to audit a course
in the american university system
auditing is when you take a course
offered by an institution for no credit
or grade this primarily encompasses
attending lectures without participating
in examinations in an effort to learn
more about a particular topic depending
on the institution or platform you're
able to access assignments or projects
to work on independently without
receiving feedback
auditing a class may also require
official instructor permission
in an online format auditing a class
usually entails having access to lecture
videos notes and or previous assignments
in other words a complete outline of the
course without the personalized
interaction with professors teaching
assistants lab instructors or other
students
online communities can be a substitute
for such traditional class support
we encourage you to explore methods of
engaging with other learners some of
which we'll discuss later
but first some background
auditing classes has long been an option
for students enrolled at an educational
institution to potentially forego paying
or receiving a grade for a class whether
because of time financial constraints or
difficulty of course material
since the inception of the internet
auditing university courses has appeared
in multiple forms one of the earliest
examples of a formalized
institution-supported platform for
taking online courses was mit's open
courseware which is operated since 2002
and posted hundreds of variations of
their courses to audit
other public platforms have also
supported this mission and posted their
material for free
more recently coursera was built as a
premium version of this type of auditing
in some circumstances providing a more
formal education closer to an accredited
degree
college compendium is another free
resource that you can take advantage of
to find free public
class resources there are many such
resources including dozens of amazing
github repositories compiling computer
science courses
it may often seem that when comparing
your options for learning on the web
you're choosing between a structured or
a customizable curriculum
with an organized curriculum you always
know what you're supposed to do next you
can be confident that someone who likely
has a strong understanding of the
material that you aim to learn has taken
the time to arrange the order of your
learning in a beneficial way
alternatively the benefit of choosing a
customizable curriculum
to learn from several disparate
resources in the order of your choice
has the benefit of being well suited to
your personal needs and learning style
however combining resources can also
cause overlapping redundant learning as
well as perhaps a less comprehensive
overview of your material
auditing courses on the web is a great
resource for the intellectually curious
that provides a cost-conscious
low-risk organized format for academic
exploration that has the benefit of
being inexpensive or free as opposed to
boot camps online degree programs and
certifications and structured compared
to navigating videos blogs and
informational articles
through auditing you gain the benefits
of both an organized college curriculum
with the ability to customize your
learning to your needs combining aspects
of each format for online learning to
negate the drawbacks of both
auditing is an amazing option if you're
serious about learning something new
while being conscious about your time
and cost constraints
auditing can also be more specialized
since expensive boot camps or courses on
the other end of the spectrum are often
limited in number and scope or built for
training and vocational purposes
specifically learning from college
computer science courses on the web
may expose you to purely academic
material including more theoretical and
low-level programming concepts
for example a youtube tutorial may teach
you how to build a python game
but it might not dive quite as deep into
the details regarding how the underlying
code functions
you must decide and choose for yourself
the level of understanding that you're
comfortable with
i find that i'm happier when i
understand the underlying processes
powering the code that i'm working with
and so when learning about neural
networks for example i might audit a
basic linear algebra course before
tackling gans
auditing is just one component of an
ecosystem of resources on the web that
exists to help people learn at no cost
many of these resources complement one
another and are used interchangeably by
platforms and courses supplementarily
such as much of the content and free
code cam
there's a lot of goodwill in open source
online learning supporting making
curriculums better and improving the
availability of information
now that i've given an overview of
auditing in our next section we'll
discuss why you should consider trying
it
all right so now that we know what it
actually means to audit a college course
let's kind of summarize the last two
lessons and think about
why are we telling you all of this
so first we talked about structured
learning versus auto didactic
self-guided learning and we talked about
how the internet is really the greatest
resource for self-guided learning and
how if you can learn how to learn
you can be like crazy powerful
and in the previous lesson
seth talked about what it actually means
to audit a course on the internet and so
the question is
bridging those two together why like why
are we talking about auditing college
courses within the context of all of
these different learning opportunities
on the internet and so our idea is that
auditing college courses is a great
medium for
getting comfortable with more
self-guided learning because when it
comes to auditing college courses it's
not nearly as easy as what it would be
being in school but it's also not nearly
as difficult as i don't know what's out
there you know what's the content what
am i even doing here
so really auditing college courses is
bridging formal education with this
self-guided learning because when you're
auditing college courses you have the
benefit of a few things you have
structured curriculum
that is produced by an accredited
institution great institutions
you have a major selection of content
that you can choose from
and it's free to use
so when you think about
learning in the structured way you have
the structured curriculum that's laid
out by the professor teaching the course
right that's something we're familiar
with and it's produced by an accredited
institution again this is content that
you know
going back to a few of those points
about what it means to learn in a
structured environment you know that
it's sequenced right that the content is
accurate and that it's of good quality
on the other hand looking towards the
autodidactic side you have so many
different types of content you can
choose from there are so many different
ways and time periods and places you can
learn from which is that flexibility and
it's free to use so again you're
bridging self-guided learning and
structured learning
so that's why we want to help you learn
how to audit college courses on the
internet
so again thinking about you know why
would i do this like what benefit do i
have well let's think about some
examples let's say that you are a high
school student or college student
applying to a program
and you are interested in that
university or that institution well
what's a better way to get to know that
institution than to take a course that's
offered for free by that institution
exposing you to department faculty
teaching style different types of
material covered and i don't know maybe
you can build a relationship
with the professors or some of the
students who are also taking that course
or who produce that course so if you're
interested in applying to let's say mit
well there's no better resource than mit
opencourseware to get a sense of the
different majors the different content
offered under the different majors the
learning style and thinking about is
this a good place for me to go attend
well let's say that you're currently an
enrolled student and maybe your program
doesn't offer a certain type of content
or a certain course or certain topic
well this is another great way to
broaden your horizons and learn
something that you otherwise wouldn't
learn so as an enrolled student by
auditing a college course you can
supplement your current courses so maybe
you know you're really bad at linear
algebra and so you need to go look at
mit open courseware's linear algebra
course to supplement that
maybe you're just generally interested
in exploring different academic areas
and you don't want to pay for a class
or your institution just doesn't offer
it
and again take more advanced courses
than those that are offered at your
school
so whether you are on the younger side
and you have not
apply to a school or in school it's a
great way to learn about a school
if you are currently in school or you've
graduated and you're just interested in
supplementing
something that you're learning this is
another great resource
number three
young
slightly older and now let's say you're
20 years into your career and you just
hate it you're absolutely love it and
you want to change careers or maybe you
do like your career but you just want to
upskill because you want to get a
promotion
well auditing a college course is again
a really great resource for doing so
because it's
meritocratically
making you a better
candidate for positions or just
generally giving you the skills
to switch careers so if you're looking
to up skill or change careers you can
explore a new subject or career areas
build context for exactly what you need
to know and what you need to do to get a
job and ultimately stay competitive
within your job or industry and reach
any goals that you've set out to do
now it's getting old pretty quickly um
no pun intended there's a lot of use
cases and just generally i think what a
lot of people watching this video can
relate to is this general use case of
you know you're interested in learning
something
new just for fun or you just want to
freshen up on an old topic and when you
think about all these courses out there
you can freshen up on so many skills or
learn so many new skills
if you are a you know mid career
professional and maybe you're not up to
date with the cool programs and
frameworks that the kids are using you
can have better context for uh what is
being used in industry because it's
usually followed
concurrently in these courses and so you
can kind of get a refresher on what's
new and what's exciting and just
generally develop more advanced
understanding of familiar topics
those are four
well thought out use cases and there are
just so many more i mean there's so many
reasons for why you want to take
a college course audit a college course
and i think that the overarching reason
is that one it's a great gap it's a
great bridge between this gap between
structured learning and self-guided
learning and that is going to make you
well equipped going forward to learn on
the internet just generally however you
do it
and this is a great way it's a great
introduction to learning on the internet
and really
the second takeaway is that
whoever you are wherever you are
there is going to be a great use case
for why you should audit a college
course in the next section seth is going
to help you think about what topic to
choose
are you excited to start learning on the
web
first we need to determine the topic
you're most interested in expanding your
knowledge on what are you interested in
why are you interested in that topic
what are you hoping to gain from
learning about it how excited are you
about spending your free time learning
your chosen topic did you choose the
topic for independent study or is it a
compliment or component of an ongoing
curriculum
your answers will help you figure out
what you want to learn and why
deciding on a topic to focus your
attention on can be difficult there are
so many interesting things to learn but
that is one of the beauties of auditing
you can dip your toes into many
different areas quickly and easily and
so picking a topic is a small commitment
if you're having trouble deciding
between several i'd consider which
topics will be most useful in the short
term or what you're the most curious
about
on the other hand if you're interested
in auditing generally but struggling to
find something you're passionate about
studying
consider actionable content
some of this plays into assessing your
goals which i'll discuss shortly but
it's a good idea to think about what
draws you to online learning have you
always wanted to learn how to build an
app or a website or a game
are you looking to expand your data
science skills by learning about neural
networks and support vector matrixes
are you trying to practice and improve
your skills for coding interviews these
motivations should be reflected in the
course that you ultimately decide to
audit once you have a general idea of
what you want to learn about
acknowledging your skill level is also
critical to picking the right course
consider how much do you know about and
how much exposure do you have to your
topic of choice
have you had formal instruction on this
topic in the past
a lot of courses out there are
inherently sorted by proficiency
prerequisites which themselves contain
information within the scope of the
topic will help you identify where you
will fall in terms of competence and
where you should begin
for example if you're coming from a
beginning standpoint maybe avoid
auditing a graduate level course
finally as i've brought up before
recognizing your goals is essential
going into the course contemplate what
do you want to walk away with
is there something specific you want to
leave the course understanding
if the course is applied what do you
want to finish having built or having
the capability to build
are you aiming to build skills to pass
an interview
if you can identify what you're working
towards you'll be more focused and more
highly value your progress
i also want to note however that
learning is just as much about the
journey as it is about the destination
reducing your audit to simply a list of
check boxes that you have to slog
through to achieve your goals is a
negative mindset that will cause you to
have an inferior learning experience
and potentially lead to some of the
pitfalls i'll discuss in greater detail
later
let's bring together the three things i
encourage you to assess
interests skill level and goals
and consider an example
say i'm a student interested in app
development with limited experience but
i have a project in mind i want to build
a dating app for scientists called
radioactive dating
where should i start
app development is a broad area and i
need to pick a particular topic for my
course
for one thing i'll have to decide what
framework to learn these days there are
many amazing options for app development
i could build valuable native
development skills by picking up swift
or kotlin but then i'd have to
compromise by only releasing the app on
one platform
alternatively i could learn react native
or ionic angular to apply my existing
stronger web dub skills to this project
and achieve cross-platform compatibility
but with maybe slightly reduced app
performance
or i could even learn dart based flutter
and achieve similar native performance
in a cross-platform code base but at the
cost of picking up a brand new framework
with less support than either
alternative
this example isn't meant to be a
commentary on what the best app
development framework is because these
are all great in different situations
but this is just one of many decisions
i'm gonna have to make in this scenario
without knowing much about any of these
options
and it's no small commitment either so
how should i go about doing it
research is key
first i should read any of the great
articles on the web comparing and
contrasting these frameworks to ensure
that i'm making an informed decision
before committing to learning a
particular choice
reading course descriptions and syllabi
is also a great way to find out this
information i would also consider my
background and my limitations as an
existing web developer with little time
ionic angular or react native could be
more desirable due to their familiarity
and therefore quicker learning curve
now that i've picked a topic it's time
to consider my skill level
even though i know web development i'm
still a beginner when it comes to apps
so i'll start with something entry-level
choosing an introductory course for
react native rather than jumping into a
higher level class will probably lead to
a better experience and if it is too
easy i can always move up
i now have determined my interest react
native
my skill level beginner and my goal a
basic dating app
if some of these specific terms that i
used in this example sound like a load
of gibberish don't worry
making these decisions can quickly
become complex it's such a plethora of
options
the best thing that you can do is make
sure that you're informed about what you
really want to be learning you do not
want to be a prospective data science
student halfway through learning php
before you realize it's maybe not quite
the best tool for that interest
here are some of the popular topics
students have searched for on college
compendium
as you can see python is incredibly
popular additionally algorithms and data
structures are close behind which
supports the idea that auditing can also
help you gain a stronger understanding
of fundamentals and foundational
material
learning from the web gives you the
capability to choose whatever it is that
you're fascinated by and focus on any
aspect that interests you or that helps
you fulfill your academic and
professional goals
assessing your interests skill level and
goals will help you make this decision
but ultimately choosing the right topic
often comes down to a gut feeling of
genuine excitement or strong motivation
i encourage you to experiment
the nice thing about having full control
over your learning is that if any time
you decide you're more interested in
another topic or another way of
approaching the same topic
you can switch to that
explore your options and indulge your
curiosity
being intentional about what you're
looking to get out of your education can
be extremely helpful in guiding your
decisions and keep you motivated as you
progress through your audit
great now that you have a topic in mind
and you've thought about how do i
actually choose a topic to learn we're
going to talk about choosing the right
class
now unless you're studying something
super niche where there may only be one
or two courses available on the internet
to audit
there's a lot of benefit to really
thinking thoroughly before you start a
course about which course which class is
right for me to take on this topic
for example for something like
algorithms and computer science there's
a dozen or so courses on the internet
that you can take
and there are differences between those
courses and you know a benefit of the
internet is that you have the choice
between those 12 and so really thinking
about which one to take is super
valuable and that's what the section is
going to talk about how to choose the
right class to audit
so first and foremost you should be
thinking about your learning type and i
think the way to think about this is to
reflect on the best classes you've taken
and what made them effective for you do
you like lecturing do you like seminar
style discussion
do you enjoy kind of getting a brief
overview about a topic and diving in
yourself do you like being guided
thoroughly with examples by the
professor
thinking about what classes you've taken
and exactly why they were effective for
you is super helpful for thinking about
the type of content you're going to be
learning and what styles you're most
accustomed to
conversely also thinking about which
courses you've taken that you just hated
and again why that was and you know if
it's about the content that's one thing
but i think the important thing to
reflect on is what you were doing in the
classroom and what made it effective
what made it ineffective
and considering that as you're choosing
courses because you'll see that again
different professors different
universities same topic they teach a lot
of this in very different ways based on
sequence based on the explanation they
may start from one angle compared to
another professor so think about how do
you learn and how should you factor that
into the course you choose
learning type very important two time
commitment
some courses are extremely thorough
extremely in-depth and maybe it just
doesn't fit with your time commitment or
isn't something you can stretch out over
multiple weeks so thinking about how
much time you have to commit to the
class will you have the time to go
through the optional readings and the
notes that come with the class to do the
assignments which often come with a lot
of these classes that you audit online
what could happen to change your time
commitment maybe in the next few weeks
or months or a year and how does that
impact your goals for the course
also thinking about if you've taken
online courses previously what was your
time commitment then how did that work
out and you know adjusting it based on
what your schedule is like
because courses again can really vary in
how much content they offer
you can have an algorithms course that
does an hour on a certain topic just
straight up high level basic
introduction to this topic versus
another course where you have a two hour
lecture another hour of reading and
another assignment so thinking about
time commitment when choosing a course
to audit is very important
third is the institution and how the
content is being delivered and so if
you're one of those individuals who
maybe is interested in a certain
university or you trust that this
university has the best content you're
thinking about is there an institution
in mind
you know i personally think that the
quality across universities is
pretty normalized and wherever you go to
audit a course you're going to get great
content but if you have an institution
in mind you really should be thinking
about
why and should i choose that institution
if they offer a course on that topic
and you know when thinking about the
content and how it's being delivered
thinking about again not just the
lecture style or your learning style but
is the lecturer writing on chalkboard
are they referencing written notes are
there powerpoint slides is it audio only
is it a video lecture with slides is it
a video lecture without slides is it a
professor who just goes through the
python documentation to teach you how to
learn python
a lot of courses do it differently and
getting an idea of
where
first where you may be interested in
learning the content from but also how
the content is being delivered is super
important because some people really
love slides other people could not care
for them anymore
so
thinking three about the institution and
how the content is being delivered and
so thinking about these different
factors for choosing which course to
audit your learning type your time
commitment your personal goals what
institution you want to take it from how
the content is being delivered
that's something that can be difficult
to assess if you're talking about 15 20
courses on a topic
and when you think about reviews and
comments people believe again it can be
hard to assess
and so what i recommend is taking an
experimentation
approach to
evaluating these courses so instead of
having to audit 20 separate courses on
one topic you can get a sense of each
one before you dive into a particular
one you can read the course description
the syllabi
any high level information about the
structure and delivery of the course
learning goals prerequisites for the
course institution and non-institution
specific and just materials to review
before you take so reading just the
general description about the course and
the syllabus is super important
and once you've evaluated that another
thing you can do um if you feel
comfortable with proceeding with that
course and if it you know matches what
you're looking for
go to the first lesson
work through the lecture material
work through any supplementary material
and kind of take note about how the
material is presented
if your comprehension has improved as a
result of it
you know if the content is far beyond
what you understand or if it's you know
far behind what you understand and you
need something more advanced or more
beginner and just thinking about okay
after this first lesson is this a course
i'd be comfortable fully auditing
through
so before you really dive into a
specific course on this topic that
you've chosen
think about
what will make this course successful
for me and what course would be the best
in theory for me to take for you to
learn that topic and don't feel like
because you've committed to a course
that you need to
follow through with it entirely or that
you need to check out the first 10
lessons of every course before you take
it you can get a great sense of what the
course is going to offer you before you
really dive in and by doing this you're
going to save yourself a lot of time and
grief trying to learn
based on a style you're not comfortable
with or a time frame or type of content
or a lecturing style whatever it is that
doesn't match what you're looking for
let's get the most out of your audit
putting strong consideration into
scheduling accountability and available
resources will help you succeed the most
difficult part of taking an online
course often isn't getting started but
rather pushing forward when the work
becomes more time consuming and
difficult
just like any in-person course
understanding your time commitment
within the context of the class
should help you make more effectively
evaluate your schedule going forward
how can you work your audit into your
schedule
if there's a time sensitive nature to
learning your selected material
think about how the quality of your
learning might be impacted by a quicken
pace
what information do you need to know it
may make sense to prioritize some parts
of a course over others
while educators and content creators
often put a lot of thought into the
organization and structure of their
course that doesn't always mean it's the
perfect fit for you
for example when learning from a public
online course on data structures the
first few weeks might be a review of c
plus if you already know c plus really
well and you feel confident that you
don't need to start from scratch you can
move forward and always return if
necessary while we caution against
skipping material when possible one of
the biggest draws of online learning is
certainly this ability to customize your
learning
if you return to the earlier
contemplation that led you to choose a
specific topic and course
what are you hoping to get out of this
course and therefore
what schedule enables you to make the
most of your learning
if you have no frame of reference for
how much you'll need to study
course web pages often have times listed
on them for when students attended class
during the in-class offering if
applicable
you can potentially use that information
to figure out what the weekly time
commitment was for other students and
then extrapolate on that for your needs
everyone has slightly different levels
of commitment if you're ambitious feel
free to start strong with several hours
of study a week
if possible try to avoid overloading
yourself from day one which can lead to
feeling burnt out but at the same time
learning often and on a regular basis is
a good method for success
above all i find that consistency is key
if you can learn a little bit every day
or even every other day even setting
aside half an hour
that can lead to sustainable and
impactful learning
staying on track is hard don't feel bad
if you miss a day
one of the easiest things that you can
do though to help you meet your
scheduled milestones is turn on
notifications for your calendar or use a
to-do list app when your phone notifies
you when it's time to learn that's an
easy way to remind yourself and keep
yourself on track
i know that setting aside designated
blocks of time in my calendar really
helps me with following through on my
audit however that might not work well
for you and so it is important to
determine how you want to set your pace
and track your progress early on
even if you use traditional paper and
pencil
it's maybe a good idea to not just wing
it i think of self-guided learning is
similar to running when you first start
it's pretty difficult to even run a mile
but as you keep at it it gets easier and
easier and eventually you feel as though
it's a natural part of your lifestyle
that you feel weird without doing and
also like running you feel amazing when
you're done
online courses can be long
breaking your chosen course down into
smaller short-term goals is another easy
way to make your path feel less daunting
or intimidating
and also more rewarding
if you value extrinsic validation then
you can also use short-term milestones
as motivation by treating yourself when
you achieve those goals
for example you can earn as you learn by
rewarding yourself with the dessert
after
a successful learning session
i enjoy watching an episode of whatever
my family is currently watching at the
time after meeting my goal of listening
to a lecture recording for the day
and even if you set aside plenty of time
daily to learn
that time is worth significantly less if
you don't stay engaged avoid
multitasking and double screening if
you're feeling bored that's a possible
indicator that this might not be the
right course for you but try to be
persistent remember it's impossible to
fail a free online course with no grades
if you're struggling with something take
your time
review the material and chat with other
people learning online for help
and speaking of chatting with other
online learners that is probably one of
the best ways to ensure your desired
outcome of finishing the course
well you're probably fairly
self-motivated and driven to even be
listening to me right now
everyone can do with some peer support
from time to time
finding someone to hold you accountable
is a great way to make sure you put in
continuous effort find a friend to audit
the class with you
find someone to ask you about your
progress often or naturally put yourself
into a position to get asked about your
work
try accountability study tools like ours
shout out to my guy calyx to keep me
motivated
there are also many great resources
available for online learners
from stack overflow and github forums if
you're not familiar with those they're
basically the twin pillars holding up
the entire programming community
to reddit communities and discord
servers there are several awesome places
to seek out other learners for help and
support and if you run into any issues
with a problem set or you encounter a
bug that you just can't figure out
chances are there are people who will
help
there are several common pitfalls that
auditors often experience
but they all ultimately lead to the same
thing not completing the course
throughout your audit evaluate if you
notice any of these things becoming
habits
setting a set enough time for your audit
can be difficult your time is valuable
and easily filled you'll have to decide
how important your audit is to you and
how to prioritize it in your schedule
your initial plan doesn't need to be set
in stone and feel free to readjust as
needed to better fit your lifestyle
at the same time though as we've
discussed before
it's important to keep a measure of
consistency if you're feeling
overwhelmed or dealing with difficult
material take a break and ask for help
when you set aside half an hour to learn
consider putting your phone on do not
disturb or the equivalent if you're
spending your allotted studying time
responding to texts or browsing twitter
that doesn't really count i can you know
i've done it too
it's relatively common midway through a
course to lose energy or focus
while it's healthy to take a break
if it's important to you that you cover
all the course material make sure to set
a date to return to your learning in
advance so it doesn't become an
overextended hiatus where you begin to
forget important information
not engaging with other online learners
is another common trap
there is a thriving community
surrounding online education
take advantage of it you're welcome to
join forums and ask for feedback and
advice and i really want to emphasize
this don't be afraid to ask for help you
should not contact the creator of the
course unless they explicitly say you
can and i say that from experience
you should also search the web for your
question first but if you don't find a
relevant answer other learners in online
communities will be happy to help
even if you're confident in your
understanding of the material finding
social support and community with other
people learning on the web
even if you're focusing on different
topics can be beneficial for your mental
health and make you feel more engaged
one of the main differences between
auditing a course online and taking it
at an accredited institution but besides
receiving official credit for it of
course
is the personal support that you receive
from teachers teachers assistants peer
mentors and friends
if you can find other online learners
that fill some of those roles it may
improve your experience you may not find
anyone and interacting with people over
the web can always involve some level of
risk but it might be worth a shot
finally although i encouraged you to set
your own pace before i'd also warn
against flying through material watching
lectures at two times speed will mean
that they'll be over faster but your
understanding and retention of the
material might be hampered too
skipping material can also be fine if
you're really confident you know it
already
but sometimes it's nice to review things
you're choosing to spend your time
learning this so i again encourage you
to find value in the process of learning
just as much of the end goal of gaining
this knowledge
if your goal from the outside is to
thoroughly cover all the material in
your course consider keeping these
pitfalls in mind as you learn
you can also enrich your learning
through complementary resources
often educators will link to relevant
complementary material for your use
from public textbooks like those linked
on the college compendium textbooks page
to youtube series to other free code
camp courses and articles you can expand
far beyond the extent of the resources
provided in the course you're currently
auditing
you can even dive into academic papers
with sites like papers with code an
amazing resource for anyone looking to
improve their understanding of
cutting-edge technologies
if you're auditing a course on the web
chances are there will exist an answer
to any question you encounter whether
you're in need of clarifying explanation
or you're curious about the deeper
workings of a subject there will be
something or someone able to help
all of this is to say that there's a lot
of actions you can take to improve your
auditing experience and make the most of
your time we encourage you to do so
you've added a course what next
before moving on ensure you've fully
reviewed the material and understand
everything of importance there's little
point to doing this if you walk away
without a strong comprehension of the
content
at this point you've completed your
course have you reached your goals
do you have all the skills you'll need
for that project you wanted to build or
an internship or position that you've
been aiming for
either way congratulations
finishing a course is an incredibly
impressive achievement and you should
feel amazing be proud of yourself a
successful audit demonstrates strong
motivation and effort but there's always
more to learn your online education is
never finished the question is simply
about how to proceed in the short term
if you're looking to learn a specific
skill set like machine learning and data
science chances are one course won't be
enough
therefore sequencing courses to
effectively audit unofficial degree can
be
incredibly useful there are many many
resources on the web where people have
compiled courses to create pathways for
becoming highly skilled through
successive auditing
for example starting with a high-level
math and introductory python course then
learning data structures
then learning an overview of neural
networks and then a more specific course
on generative adversarial networks
in other words following a trajectory
similar to a real curriculum where you
start with foundations of a topic and
build on those gradually becoming more
specific
another incredibly valuable part of
auditing public courses on the web is
the ability to mix and match courses
from various sources
you can learn one topic from a school
like mit then the next one was
universities such as harvard and then
the next from a college like berkeley
this ability to interchange your
learning allows you to pick the classes
that appeal the most to you potentially
creating a learning experience worth
more than the sum of its parts
math is fundamental to programming
especially so for data science if you're
looking to audit computer science it's
also worth considering adding classes
covering concepts in statistics
calculus
linear algebra and discrete math to your
custom curriculum
these courses will provide a stronger
foundation for your understanding of key
concepts in computer science such as
algorithms and data structures
before i wrap this section up i wanted
to give a shout out to the github
student developer pack if you're a
student enrolled in any educational
institution then this is a no-brainer
bundle of free resources for programming
including free domains hosting and the
pro versions of jetbrains ides
freedom is a central theme of online
self-guided learning choose your own
content based on your interests choose
your learning format your teacher and
the source of your class
choose your schedule
choose what you learn next it's all up
to you
with the knowledge you've gained in this
video you're informed to make these
decisions and achieve your goals through
auditing
up next we have a few examples where we
audited real courses blog style based on
the information discussed in this course
okay
one way that i learn is through examples
and so
in the spirit of learning through
examples seth and i are going to take
you through an example
of what we just talked about summarizing
all of it
essentially thinking about a topic
thinking about a course to take
evaluating it and ultimately auditing it
so let's get started
for me um recently i've been doing two
things i've been working on coding
interviews and i have been working on
personal projects
and doing both of those things has
taught me something about myself
and that's that i am really bad at
solving problems in a computationally uh
efficient manner
i found that with a lot of coding
interviews and also with the side
projects i work on i'm usually solving
things in a very belabored manner i
could probably consolidate that down
in addition to kind of what i've been
doing
in a few terms i have an algorithms
course
that i'm going to be taking that i'm
super excited for but i also don't
really know much about algorithms and i
have a feeling that maybe taking an
algorithms course will not only prepare
me for
what i'll be taking in the future but
also like for now may help me with like
coding interviews and understanding time
complexity
memory and just like computational
intensity so i think and i haven't taken
an algorithms course before
so i think i'm going to take an
algorithms course
and you know i have classes that start
pretty soon so i don't have a lot of
time probably a week and i think i'm
just going to spend like an hour to a
day watching lectures maybe taking notes
and just getting a sense of what i'm in
for maybe it'll solve my
coding interview woes in the short term
and long term i'll be prepared for my
algorithms course
so
lucky for me there's a few
algorithms courses quite a few because
it's um really the core part of a lot of
computer science curriculums
so when i go to college compendium i'm
just going to search for algorithms
in the top right and you know see which
courses i can come across and you can
already see there are so many
a waterloo design analysis of algorithms
course
there's an mit design and analysis
you toronto washington
it looks like some of these courses are
pretty advanced and i'm very far from
being advanced when it comes to
algorithms
so i think i'm going to look for a
course that isn't too advanced
so looking through these okay mit fall
2011 an introduction to algorithms
course i don't think algorithms change
like that often so
maybe
fall 2011 that will work
it says this course provides an
introduction to mathematical modeling of
computational problems it covers common
algorithms algorithmic paradigms and
data structures used to solve these
problems
pretty straightforward
i'm personally a fan of mit
opencourseware they never really missed
when it comes to these courses so
and they have video lectures so i i
think this could be a good course to
take so i'm just going to open this in a
new tab
and i'm actually just going to look at
the syllabus and get a sense of
the prerequisites and
what the time frame was when people were
taking this course
when it was recorded
so it looks like two sessions a week one
hour session okay that's good i can you
know do one hour lecture sessions
also recitations two sessions a week one
hour session
so it seems like there's a bit of
supplementary material when it comes to
um
learning in this algorithms course
um let's see prerequisites a firm grasp
on python i don't know if firm is the
right word but i know python a solid
background and discrete again solid i
don't know about that but i've taken a
discrete mathematics course
and um look they even link to
courses introduction to eeks and
mathematics for computer science so
um
i think that i have covered those areas
sufficiently so this is perfect based on
my prerequisites
um they also are linking
a book a textbook to buy introduction to
algorithms
and
another one that uses python okay
um
lectures and recitations you're
responsible for material presented in
lectures including oral comments
okay problem sets um seven problem sets
during the course of the semester so i
go once every two weeks
quizzes grading policy great
so
that seems doable and you can see
unit one
algorithmic thinking peak finding models
of computation python cost model
document distance
and problem set one that corresponds to
that
so
you know that's five lectures right
there an hour each and a problem set
i think that could be a good start for
understanding
um the lectures and you can see the
problem set one pdf is here the code's
here and oh it even has the uh solutions
which is going to be super helpful
and yeah this this definitely looks
doable
so
this looks like a great course for me so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
watch the first lecture video and see if
it's doable if i understand the content
and then go from there maybe even start
on problem set one and i will see you
then
great so i just finished watching the
first lecture
and i found it to be pretty much in line
with where i'm at with my understanding
in fact the first like 10 minutes or so
the professor reviewed like what is to
come in the course which i found to be
super helpful and clarifying um just
going forward with like a future
material
and i took some notes here and i
actually i looked at the lecture notes
that are corresponding to the lecture
um and it's interesting because it's
really a consolidated version of the one
hour lecture so i may just end up
looking at these um
for like doing problem sets and stuff
but yeah you know at a cursory glance
looking at the first lecture it seems
like this is a course that i can
you know get a few
get a get a few lessons out of um and i
can follow along with the content i
don't find it too fast or too slow
and i feel like you know now he's
actually solving one of the problems uh
that i saw in an interview so it looks
like this is going to be a good course
for the purpose that i'm looking for and
it seems doable over the next week so
i'm ready to audit this course i think
it's going to be great and i'm excited
to see where it goes
well i hope you enjoyed sam sort of
informally giving you
his thought process behind using the
things we've discussed in this video to
choose a course
i'm going to try and do the same but as
i already watched the first few lectures
i'm going to offer a more retrospective
approach
so i chose to audit a data structures
course
and
i really want to learn the logic behind
a lot of the abstractions that i use in
programming
i've heard of these concepts linked
lists tree and graph traversal and even
different methods of sorting
but i don't really have a strong
understanding of them
and i know that
understanding data structures is really
critical to being able to make decisions
as a programmer
so the course that i picked is
cs61b data structures from berkeley
um and i found it through college
compendium just by searching for data
structures on the website
and
this course is special because it has an
enrollment of sixteen hundred students
and so what that means is that the court
is designed in a way that doesn't
require much teacher interaction and the
teacher themselves explains this in the
first lecture like if they give every
kid a minute of time it would take more
than a day
and so
in addition to that it's also very
recent um it was made in spring of 2021
and so the material is relatively new
and it's very nice because it is links
to every lectures slides and thorough
notes outlining all of the important
information in the videos as well as
acting as guides for what i need to do
next
most of the code is available freely on
github and they have crazy in-depth
resources with
guides documentation review material and
so on
and so not all courses are created equal
for auditing publicly on the web and i
do encourage you to make sure that the
course you choose has everything you
want before you start it
but
another part of why this course was a
good fit for me
was because it's very heavily lab and
project based so i really enjoy projects
as a method for learning
um because it gives me something to work
towards and it's just more fun
building 2048
was uh the first project for this class
i'm excited to see what the ones to
follow involve so this course started
with a review of java and this was good
because i haven't really used java much
since ap computer science a
going over syntax and static typing but
it also goes over things like get the
programming version control tool
and i can safely skip get because i've
even made resources teaching get such as
ultimate get resource available on
github
and
what i want to say here as well is that
if you
know
any concept well enough to teach it
then that's a really good way to ensure
that you understand it it's also just a
good method for
going over your material and potentially
even helping other people to learn it as
well the last thing i want to touch on
before passing it back to sam
is that when i first looked at this
course it's 16 weeks long
it can be a little bit intimidating
you know all of the material that i have
to cover
in addition to being a full-time student
and having projects and research and so
on
and so
something that i like to do is
compartmentalize my approach for
auditing and so i'm gonna just do just
this lecture this week or just this
assignment
and
i don't know if that will necessarily be
the most helpful thing for you
but it's something to consider
regardless i'm really excited to
continue auditing this course and i hope
you're excited to begin yours
so thank you so much for watching um
really appreciate it if you found it
helpful let us know if you have any
questions
please comment down below and we will
make sure to answer
and if there's one
note that i want to leave off on
as long as you are
taking the initiative to find a course
because you enjoy a topic or you want to
learn it and you're listening to
lectures and reading notes and doing
assignments that's good enough
and so don't be discouraged if you
don't finish a course or you leave it
early
because really it's about learning and
getting comfortable with learning in
what is a very uncomfortable way to
learn what matters is that you're
learning and you're taking the
initiative and you're bettering yourself
in the process
thank you for listening to our course we
hope that you come away feeling prepared
and excited to learn by auditing courses
on the web
if you're not sure where to start try
searching for your topic of interest on
collegecompendium.org
where we've created hundreds of
resources in all manner of popular
programming areas or search free code
camp
thank you again to quincy larson from
free code camp for supporting this
course
that's all folks good luck